hoy ganó la ciudadanía hoy ganó colombia
ahora entramos al segundo tiempo y estos
próximos días serán decisivos para
determinar el futuro del país soy
consciente de la necesidad de unir
nuestro país en el camino de cambio que
hoy se ha hecho evidente
contundentemente
y soy consciente de las dificultades que
vendrán cuando asuma la presidencia de
la república
no soy lleno
respecto a las resistencias que habrán
frente al gobierno decidido a acabar con
la politiquería y la corrupción
especial por parte de algunos de los que
se han sentido dueños de este país
pero soy consciente de que será el
pueblo colombiano quien me acompañe en
la defensa de las decisiones que deben
tomar
y que será este pueblo con quien
construirá la victoria en segunda vuelta
a quienes me botaron quiero decirles que
no les fallaré
y que no descansaré un minuto en el
cumplimiento de mi compromiso con todos
ustedes
mi compromiso es hoy y será siempre
hacer de colombia un país con
oportunidades para todos donde el
gobierno trabaje cada día para el
bienestar de los colombianos en especial
los más necesitados de apoyo
gracias colombianos
y colombianas cuento con ustedes para
ganar en segunda vuelta y así poder
concretar este gran camino que ustedes
han votado hoy no quiero dejar pasar
mi reconocimiento
a la manera precisa concreta espontánea
rápida y seguro como la como la
registraduría entregó los resultados
mil gracias señor registrador
vivacolombia